eh bien,
allez-y,
ok, nous procédons au
est ouais GRE
C d'entre
nous, vous voyez du vert parce que ouais ouais, c'est
ok oui monsieur, ok, avez-vous besoin de
CL plus euh
Qu'est-ce euh
pour
jaob
beaucoup de beaucoup de 50 Fe poids vous
pour
nous
juste  vitesse
maintenant
ok euh
c'est ok euh c'est ok
vitesse euh
spe ouais allez
ne pas à
gauche jusqu'à droite
F à
droite
cette merde
oui
bonjour merci f
un
pourquoi
4,5
9,5
ok
r
alors
euh
avant
hein
poussez
[Applaudissements]
minutes 60
50 15
[Applaudissements]
minutes
ok
maintenant on peut tourner à droite tourner à droite oui monsieur
monsieur et euh euh quand on y va quand on
est près du jardin on va
réduire à 40 à 50 nœuds ok ok merci
très bien,
tourne à droite encore plus à
droite ouais on arrive par cette vallée jusqu'au
jardin et puis on tourne à gauche dans l'
autre vallée
[Applaudissements]
ok [
Applaudissements]
d'
avance [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Applaudissements]  ]
Je
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] je
ne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] je
tourne à
droite à droite ouais à droite monsieur,
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
quand et maintenant nous pouvons descendre, descendre, ralentir,
descendre
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements  ]